ce n'est pas sans émotion que le
président Vladimir Zelinski revient à
Herson ville libérer des mains des
Russes depuis vendredi dernier
la Russie a une armée forte nous
reprenons pas à pas notre pays dans tous
les territoires occupés temporairement
nous sommes prêts pour la paix mais
notre père pour notre pays
il s'aventure même à une touche d'humour
quand on lui demande ce qui viendra
après
la prochaine étape
nous ne sommes pas intéressés par les
territoires d'un autre pays
nous ne sommes intéressés que par
l'occupation de notre pays
pour la grande majorité des habitants en
revanche la reprise par les Ukrainiens a
été fêté dans la joie et le soulagement
ces derniers jours
c'est chiant c'est une grande joie que
nos hommes soient revenus à la maison et
nous est rendu nous appartements nos
maisons et notre liberté
je ne sais pas quoi dire je suis
submergé par les émotions
pendant ce temps là en Russie on
revendique encore la ville le Kremlin a
souligné dans la matinée querson leur
appartient bien toujours
nous ne commetrons pas vous savez bien
que c'est le territoire de la fédération
de Russie
Elsa était la seule capitale régionale
aux mains des Russes depuis le début de
l'offensive en février 2021
un tout autre chose